you have a paper uh on evolutionary
stalling
where you describe that evolution is not
good at multitasking or like uh in
populations that have evolve quickly I
mean it's a very specific thing but
there could be a generalizable
fundamental thing to this that evolution
is not able to improve multiple modules
simultaneously I guess the question is
um what part of the organism does
evolution quote unquote focus on to
improve yeah that was the driving
question we meddled with the parts where
you shouldn't be messing up with
translation this is the shooter should
not you shouldn't as I said there are
many ways to break it and all life needs
it so one of the things your favorite
things to do is to break life to see
what happens
it's yeah because that's how kids learn
right so you have to break something and
you see how it will then you do over and
over again to see if it will fix itself
in the same ways yeah so that's it's our
I don't know it's the most fundamental
properties of our ourselves as human
beings so if we shouldn't break
translation then we should try to break
it yes to see how it will repair so
which part did you break I broke
elongation so what's the role of
elongation in this process so do we we
have uh four steps of the translations
initiate elongate so to elongate the
chain of the the information chain that
you're now creating the peptide chain uh
or let's say broadly polymer chain
um and there's a termination step and
there's the recycling so all of these
com steps are carried out by proteins
that are also named after these steps
initiation is the initiation Factor
protein elongation is the long elongator
protein
um
we
um
broke elongation
so the cell the starting codon could
still arrive to where it's supposed to
go but the following information
couldn't get carried out because we
replaced elongation with uh its own
ancestral version so we inserted roughly
a 700 million year old elongation Factor
protein
after removing the modern Gene so we
made this ancient modern hybrid
organism and that essentially creates in
some way the ancient version of that
organism
I wouldn't say so it
organism it's not necessary because you
because your stuff just to sell the rest
of the
uh genome is still modern and that goes
back to the difference between Jurassic
Park there are many differences
obviously given that this is not fiction
we're doing it but also
um we are not necessarily I think in
Jurassic Park they are taking and
ancients or they find an ancient
organism and then put a modern Gene
inside the ancient organism in our case
we are still working with what we got
but putting an ancestral DNA inside the
modern organisms you're like taking a
new car and putting an old engine into
it in a way yeah yes seeing what happens
yes but in our case it's more like a
Transformer than just a regular car it
is doing things it's yeah so it's a more
complicated organism than just a car
yeah uh I got it so what is that what
does that teach you
we want to
sell respond to
perturbation and we didn't just put the
ancient DNA we inserted
um we sampled DNA from currently
existing organisms so the cousins of
this microbe and and collected DNA
sequences from the cousins as well so
both ancestor and the current cousin DNA
so to speak and engineered all of these
things to the modern bacteria and
generated a collection of microbes that
either have the ancient component or the
variants
elongator component that still alive
today but coming from a different part
of the tree so you broke elongation
was that something you did as part of
the paper on evolutionary stalling to
try to figure out
how Evolution figures out what to try to
improve did that help yes because we
were not supposed to
mess with the Translate
that's exactly what we did
and we
altered elongation by changing it with
different versions of elongation that
are either coming from
species that still are around today you
can imagine them as sitting on the tips
of the Tree near Branch for our Branch
to compare to the organism that we're
working with cousins distant cousins
as well as the ancestors of the bacteria
that we are now modifying how much
different uh variation is there in that
elongation step like what are the
different flavors of elongation that's a
very good question so
mechanistically or mechanically it's the
same it's it's very conserved so all
life elongates the same way you are it's
nothing but a shuttle you just carry in
um the chemical with you
the bits to the heart of the machine is
that essentially doing like a copy paste
operation it has its tail that's
attached to the the code
which is then carried biochemically to
the linear chain to the core of ribosome
and the it sits on there it's released
and the peptides click uh the the codes
rather click once that chemistry that is
at the tail end occurs the protein
leaves the
um Center so you can imagine it's like
it hops in there and hops out and when
it pops and UPS out it leaves the
information behind that's all it does is
bring the information get out of there
and it's all triggered by biophysics
biochemistry because of the way the
enzyme chews energy in this case GTP
have the the phosphor leaves the center
the kicks that gives the additional kick
um to the enzyme to leave the center so
what which parts are different than what
where's the flavors of different flavors
usually the parts that match
that math change over time nature
conserves the sites of these proteins
that are important for it is job
if there's a difference then we we want
to know especially if if there's a
difference between two cousins and in we
look at the sites that interact with the
most important parts of this Machinery
if we see any difference we tend to
mutate or we revert we engineer that
part we alter that part because it gives
us a clue that there must be something
interesting going on here or not okay so
that's not the the fundamental part of
the Machinery but it's some flavorful
characteristic that you can play with so
now you strip the Machinery down to its
parts and now you're looking at the
parts of the parts okay and um it
depends uh where you're looking and how
you're looking and what you're looking
at but usually we see up to 70 percent
level uh conserved identity across all
modern versions when you travel back in
time the identity decreases so
elongation likely existed we have good
reason to think that it existed at the
dawn of life so you're looking at a 3.8
billion year old mechanism
and when we look at the ancestors that
we resurrect we see about 40 identity so
the identity definitely decreases as you
go back in time but still 60 percent
shared information over 4 billion year
is pretty good is that just for
elongation for the entire translation
depends on what you do so for initiation
we've also recently published this it's
a different story but overall you see
high level of identity that that is kept
intact especially if the component is
essential for life okay so 40 and 60 70
you said but like from generation to
generation how does evolution and
presumably that's what that paper is
looking at is the parts of the parts
yeah so how does it
uh able to say like mess with the parts
and try to come up with a cooler
improved version of the organism yeah so
let me describe to you what we did in
that experiment we took a different we
took bacteria we perturbed the
elongation in all of these with
different variants so we had an initial
set of
um a group of bacteria that we had we
then subjected these bacteria to
evolution in the lab all right so we
first of all we knew we broke it because
upon engineering we measured what's
going on with the cell it's not growing
as well they are not healthy we can see
it without rice we can measure it that
if they were generating an offspring
every 20 minutes now it is 40 minutes
right so we really messed them up they
don't want to work with this thing they
don't want each other but they need each
other so we created that situation for
them which is good because we want to
see how we wanted to see how they will
uh cooperate with each other uh to fix
this problem because we know that that's
not the condition that they want to live
in
especially when they know what they can
do
so with that we subjected these
organisms to evolution in the lab that's
uh
we refer to this as experimental
Evolution we subject bacteria to
different selection pressure
project them through bottlenecks every
day we randomly collect a handful of
bacteria from the flask give them put
them in a new Fresh environment with
fresh food keep them in this environment
for 24 hours until they reach a more
doormat State and then we subject
introduce them to a new environment so
we repeated this for about it
um I will say 150 days so every day not
non-stop we repeated this experiment
some kind of uh how much how many
different kinds of environments are
there I mean we kept the environments
into the same and because we had
different initial conditions we kept the
environment constant same temperature
same food same source of carbon but we
created replicates for each
lineage so in some ways we created our
own fossil record in the lab by evolving
and generating these flasks in every gen
every step of the way we all saw froze
these cells and took stocks of them in
the in the cryo freezer how long does it
take to go from one generation to the
next bacteria if you for E coli it's
usually 20 minutes
okay great so that's the experiment
that's the experiment and and you're
you're always messing it with it in the
same way for the initial it's the it's
the same way so we we introduced
variation at elongation level because
so because we um perded with different
elongations we found that if we
introduce a different protein that is
very different the cells don't like that
right so if the distance is larger the
consequences also large meaning that you
hit them harder if you introduce a
variant that is really foreign to them
that's really distant I mean if in our
case it was the ancestor they really did
not like the ancestor but they were okay
with their nearest cousin
right okay great so you did vary in the
distance we varied it to this every
evolutionary distance and then we kept
the experiment called experimental
conditions the same and we propagated
these populations every day for 150 days
and we collected
um bacteria at every step of the way and
looked at the sequence we wanted to
understand what sort of changes may have
happened in the genome to respond to
the variation that we've introduced so
what kind of changes would you be seeing
depending on the evolutionary distance
of the thing is shoved into it exactly
so we knew where we punched right we
punched right the heart right we punched
the translation so we expected is it
going to be is it translation are we
going to see a change that will
translation respond to this by fixing
itself right away or will it be
um another outside of translation
something completely different a
different module because translation
itself is a module or would it be within
elongation it really stop protein level
thing so we uh had a strategy to
identify uh the mutational pathways by
categorizing what we expected to find or
where
okay so why does it not do multitasking
it
turned out that what we observed in
general is that first of all the harder
we
hit the cells the more likely they were
to respond by changes right at where we
hit it when you say hit it you mean like
change something of it is hitting
because we are I like to think there's
this breaking the cell right I mean not
breaking enough to kill it but we still
because they're still alive they're not
doing their job well so the the bigger
the evolutionary distance of the thing
you put in there the the the the harder
the hit is how you think about it the
bigger the hammer bigger the hammer
exactly you hit it with okay if that's
what it turned out to be because that's
what the data told us that if we
um if the variation is higher than the
consequences will also be higher in the
sense that the cells will not grow as
healthy compared to a variance that is
coming from a near uh or a variance that
is coming from a near revolutionary is
it is it wrong to think of this kind of
heading as a Akin to a mutation
oh no what are we supposed to learn from
this hitting like how how the thing
evolves after is being hit in this way
what does that teach us because we
reached um
it is so conserved and so essential it
is not even clear whether we can remove
some of the parts or whether the entire
translation will need all of the same
Parts in the same efficiency we don't
understand the rules of this machinery
so the first thing we ought to
understand is that how what is the
resilience what are we really talking
about here when we talk about you cannot
mess with this translation is this true
because it is so conserved and so
similar and functions in the most
conserved ways that was the first thing
that we want to understand did you learn
anything interesting about the
resilience at the chemical physical
informatic computation no I I wouldn't
say that I think in the biological level
yes because we found that the different
modules started responding to the
changes that we've introduced and that
we could never recover the translation
as effectively as it used to be so that
it never reached to it is
um optimality that it was always
sub-optimal it needed say one more
mutation perhaps to get there it
accumulated four mutations that was we
did a lot of experiments to understand
this of course it was accumulating
mutations it was getting better at its
task maybe it needed a couple other
mutations to get really good at it but
somehow those limitations never happened
and before those mutations happened we
saw another module
um emerging through mutations and
getting better at its own different
tasks that is not translation you can
think of cell as a web of networks right
when we think of this as multiple almost
airports that are proteins that are more
Central hubs versus there are proteins
that maybe are not as important how if
you introduce a problem in the most
populated Hub you're gonna mess up the
traffic system more drastically and and
that's what we were messing with in in
the biological terms as well so when we
say module like translation would be one
of the most translation would be one so
you're basically saying when you mess
with translation
the organism would choose to either try
to fix that module or another module
depending exactly but it wouldn't do
multiple models it wouldn't do multiple
modules it focused on one module at a
time and right before that module maybe
reached to its own maximum it's stalled
its optimality at a certain degree so
you never get to a degree that is more
optimal than you can achieve even though
perhaps another mutation could get you
there since you messed with the
translation
from a sort of optimal perspective
wouldn't it make sense for the cell to
try to start fixing the translation not
that's exactly exactly what we thought
and it didn't it was not the case for
all the broken translation missionaries
for instance if the variant was coming
from a near ancestor that didn't happen
it was almost cruising around trying
different modules and sort of living its
best life still without because there is
no real urgency in the system to fix the
most important problem and there's also
not a Direction
you know maybe to you it's obvious
that's the problem but to the cell maybe
you're the problem I'm living like you
said my best life like we don't I mean I
guess that's the thing about evolution
is we don't know what the right
direction to yeah it's almost like you
can imagine that you have this messy
closet and um you know
happens to be inaccurate representation
of my life so you can't you you take a
look at it and you see all these
sweaters or you know jeans or all over
the place and then you look at a drawer
that has sucks coming out of it and you
think that's the most important one I'm
just gonna fix that one yeah and then
you fix that one and then you think you
will get to the other one but you don't
because you just fix the most important
one that is the whatever that was
getting into your way that's what really
what evolution is it's quite lazy it
fixes the problem that seems to be the
most immediate and it doesn't go beyond
what it really needs to it seems like at
least for our experimental setup that
was the case uh especially for rapidly
evolving systems so like is the
environment they're operating in pretty
constrained
like is there a urgency I would think I
would say that we definitely constrain
the environments it's definitely removed
from their natural
setup we are not evolving them in a guts
it's a very homogeneous system very
controlled controlled temperature
controlled food controlled carbon